was genau man jetzt willkommen bei einem
neuen video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
euch geht's gut ich bin wieder blond ein
bisschen zumindest ich komme gerade
frisch vom friseur
es ist echt viel blond aber das wächst
schneller aus als man gucken kann
deswegen bin ich eigentlich zufrieden
die leute im heutigen video mal hier was
was es sehr sehr lange nicht gab ich
glaube ich habe dazu früher 12 videos
mal gemacht wo ich so ein bisschen
klamotten vorgestellt habe ich habe
jetzt allerdings in kooperation mit
docyard punkt kommen eine kleine
kooperation hergestellt und zwar ist das
ein online-shop vielleicht kennen ja die
einen oder anderen von euch da gibt es
echt mega tolle sachen alles mögliche
von adidas über nike über vieler über
adidas und zone also echte menge coole
sachen und habe mir gesagt alex kommt
such dir doch mal einige sachen aus und
ich hab mir wirklich eine menge
ausgesucht und ich habe auch eine menge
bekommen es hat mich sehr gefreut ich
habe mir gedacht ich zeige euch die
ganzen sachen mal das sind ungefähr 1718
sachen zum beispiel auch schon das was
ich gerade an habe das fahre ich
eigentlich mit am meisten von fehler
richtig schöne qualität sitzt richtig
bequem sind natürlich eigentlich alles
unisex sachen also das können alles
mädchen und jungs tragen und das coole
ist ich verlinke euch alle links zu den
ganzen sachen die ich mir gekauft habe
und in der video beschreibung das heißt
wenn sie sagt diesen alters rudi möchte
ich auch oder dieses adidas shirt oder
vieler politik keine ahnung
klickt auf den link und dann solltet ihr
auf der seite können sich hier anschauen
ich will garnicht langeland wir machen
das dann auch ein bisschen ich lauf dann
so durch die gegend und präsentieren
euch die outfits wie sohn otto da
draußen im regen ist regnet scheißegal
gefangenen mit dem ersten shirt das habe
ich schon ausgepackt und zwar haben wir
hier ein adidas shirt in grün ist mehr
so in dem stoff gehalten zum sport
machen das ganze aber echt mega geil die
farbe gefällt mir richtig gut
ja ihr könnt ja auch mal in die
kommentare schreiben was sie am meisten
feiert oder was halt nicht ja dass alle
das shirt kann man super kombinieren mit
dieser dunkelblauen hose von champion
die gefällt mir auch richtig gut danke
dafür
und wie das ganze aussehen könnte das
zeige ich euch sofort denn um dem outfit
sondern kleine abordnung zu geben fehlen
natürlich noch schuhe und dafür hab ich
mir gedacht komm was stellst du doch
einfach mal hier die box und zwar sind
das die riba classic welches modell das
weiß ich nicht ist natürlich auch in der
video beschreibung verlinkt auf jeden
fall auch ein richtig cooler schuh und
so können das ganze aussehen
[Musik]
so leute machen wir weiter
und als nächstes habe ich mir diesen
pulli geholt und zwar ist das ein pulli
von der marke kappa eine marke die ich
auch echt schon richtig lange kenne wir
hatten früher mal in der
fußballmannschaft trainingsanzüge von
kappa die haben auch glaube ich mal die
italienische fußball mannschaft
ausgestattet auch die qualität richtig
richtig gut und diesen kann man ganz
entspannt irgendwie hab ich nun zeugen
bestätigt mein ganzes leben besteht aus
jogginghosen man sagt ja mal leute die
jogging hosen tragen haben die kontrolle
über ihr leben verloren
finde ich gar nicht ich hatte volle
kontrolle dazu kann man gut diese fehler
denn wo sie kombinieren zeige ich euch
auch mal wie das aussieht also wundert
euch nicht warum hier nur die hosen im
video sind film ab einen regen let's go
[Musik]
so leute wir machen weiter wir sind noch
eine menge sachen sollst nicht sitzt
haben wir wieder was von adidas und zwar
haben wir hier ein t shirt in grün ja so
sieht das aus in der größe l immer für
mich ein bisschen was heißt hatte ich
auf jeden fall noch nicht an das
probieren wir gleich mal und dieses
shirt könnte man eigentlich auch gut mit
der schwarzen hose kombinieren aber wenn
es draußen ein bisschen zu kalt ist
könnte man auch mal locker lässig ja
okay das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
gewagt hier diese gelbe jacke drüber ich
bin natürlich jetzt nicht so der fashion
könig müsste man mal schauen wie das
aussieht auf jeden fall habe ich diese
jacke auch noch dazu bekommen
die ist von new balance i glaube ich
durchaus richtig richtig geil also das
ist auch eines meiner lieblingsstücke
damit sie kannst du aus dem postbote
aber gefällt mir richtig gut das könnte
dann wie folgt aussehen
ich bin gespannt was glaubt
[Musik]
so machen wir weiter und kommen als
nächstens zu einer jogginghose of online
was heißt auch von euch vielleicht habe
ich eigentlich nur die chance
wir haben hier eine jogginghose auch in
l ich glaube was die viele jogginghose
intel war mir ein bisschen zu groß
die könnte man dann ruhig in einer
nummer kleiner nehmen also der sich auch
in m nehmen können und damit ihr
bescheid wird jack ule standard irgendwo
so von mir kennen wahrscheinlich viele
von euch und dazu könnte man sehr gut
dieses t shirt anziehen und zwar ist das
ein t shirt von scheiße wie spricht man
ja ich dachte früher einmal da steht
fucile drauf aber irgendwie heißt das ja
nicht so könnt ihr gerne in die
kommentare schreiben
die haben wir einmal vorne das
markenlogo und hinten haben wir es auch
noch drauf richtig richtig geil und das
outfit könnte man noch abschließen mit
dieser cap im gleichen tour wie das
shirt habe ich ganz bewusst gewählt auch
von der gleichen marke
rossi und ich glaube dazu bilden richtig
richtig gut nicht diese bands klapphandy
zeige ich euch gleich auch noch sondern
diese viele schuhe passen
heute schaut euch diesen schuh an für
den sommer richtig geil gefällt mir
richtig gut natürlich kann man sich auch
mal zu kaufen der 150 euro kostet oder
so keine frage
allerdings hat dieser schule habe ich
980 euro gekostet und das finde ich ein
guter preis dafür auch der über classic
hat gerade mal was heißt gerade mal ist
natürlich trotzdem viel geld für 280
euro gekostet finde ich aber vollkommen
okay und das ganze könnte es so aussehen
[Musik]
wir machen weiter mit einem pullover und
zwar ist das ein pulli von der marke
sank ja also schon im shop hat ihr stets
drauf hat 930 euro gekostet meine ich
auch richtig richtig gute qualität
das probiere ich auch mal aus den pulli
kann man auf jeden fall gut mit einer
schwarzen jogginghose einziehen können
schnell gut vorstellen natürlich auch
mit einer grauen aber wir probieren es
mit einer schwarzen und damit das ganze
richtig hässlich aussieht habe ich noch
diesen michael brecker dazu gestellt ihr
fragt euch wahrscheinlich dinger wie
viele sachen hast du denn davon
das frage ich mich gerade auch also an
dieser stelle schöne grüße an st vielen
dank für die ganzen tollen sachen gerne
wieder so ich finde manchmal gibt sachen
da denkt man sich ja ist okay dann gibt
es da ja sagt manche sind richtig
hässlich aber wenn man also sachen sie
wie zum beispiel diese jacke denke ich
mir sofort junge wiege und wie das alles
kombiniert aussieht das zeige ich euch
jetzt
[Musik]
so jetzt noch ein paar sachen zum
abschluss ich zeig euch einfach alles
auch wenn das video lange dauert ist mir
egal wir haben hier alter wir haben hier
von der marke helly hansen mannschaft
jeder von euch kennt diesen auch leicht
oversize mäßigen pullover oder ja ist
ein polyp oder besser gesagt einen
switcher vor allem von hinten sieht das
richtig nice aus könnte man auch mit
einer schwarzen hose kombinieren oder
halt einfach mit einer grauen schaue ich
gleich mal
[Musik]
sodann haben wir ebenfalls noch von
umbro kenne ich gar nicht die marke
diese drogendealer ticker jacke
da muss man aufpassen womit man das
kombiniert könnte sonst schnell so ein
bisschen als sie aussehen trotzdem
richtig geil
mal gucken ob ich da so ein richtig
richtig schönes outfit zusammen kriege
sehen wir gleich und wo ich auch richtig
gespannt bin ist bei diesem fall dass
die den habe ich ganz bewusst raus ist
einfach weil eine andere qualität hat
der ist richtig schön flauschig ich
hoffe das sieht man hier steht adidas
drauf und der hat richtig richtig welche
qualität ist er irgendwie xxl und das
outfit seht ihr jetzt
[Musik]
so leute so viel erstmal zu den
klamotten ich hoffe natürlich es hat
euch gefallen schreibt gerne in die
kommentare welches outfit fand die am
heftigsten wie gesagt noch mal schönes
dankeschön ein junkie art alle sachen
ändern videobeschleunigung verlinkt
checkt das gern mal ab bestellt euch was
könnt euch was wenn ihr wollt vielleicht
war so ein t shirt zwischendurch oder so
ansonsten sehen wir uns wahrscheinlich
morgen wieder morgen gibt's neues cooles
video
ich wünsche dir noch angenehm tag war
ein ast und folgt mir auch immer man es
nennen ist ganz wichtig und mein
kleiderschrank platzt jetzt fast
getrennt